[Music]
a lot of people say oh I was going to be
an actor I was going to be a writer I
was going to be a director but I gave it
up because I can't take rejection well
you'll always have rejection and
whatever you do if you're a plumber
you're gonna have rejection the thing is
you love it and that's your passion and
that's your joy and that's what you
expressed and you don't think about are
you gonna make a lot of money are you
gonna be famous you don't think about
things like that
or it won't happen or if it does it will
be very shallow well I was asking least
rest from how he liked me on television
and he said he thought that I wanted to
be famous more than I wanted to be an
artist and I said to him can't you be
both and he said yes not in that order
and I saw that my priorities were not in
the right order and when your priorities
are in order you can achieve everything
you want to achieve but what if your
priorities are not in order you won't
achieve anything so if you're just
wanting to be famous as I see young
people want to be well they just want to
be beautiful they're really sabotaging
themselves because what you want to be
is creative loving joyful expressing
yourself and the outcome will take care
of itself or not then there never will
be a final outcome and there's no
perfection except when you're dead
because you can never be more dead no
one can ever say if she was only more
dead it would be great it's just it's
the journey getting there I think when
anybody famous dies when you say my god
she had everything she had incredible
beauty and talents and sex appeal and
fame and the pain of not being able to
find joy in your life really made me
question myself and really made me think
about what are the important things in
life it's not looks it's not Fame it's
not diet it's not money well what is it
it's love and it's joy and it's
creativity and it's not getting am I
going to get this it's giving and it's
being able to receive it's very
important to receive a lot of people can
give but they can't receive when I come
out on stage and people start applauding
my first reaction is I want to run it's
very difficult to stay there at the end
of the show to at the curtain call it's
very difficult for me to just stand
there and I say no just receive people's
message to you their appreciation of of
how much people need to laugh and what
the point of your play is my mother's
dream for me was to be famous and my
dream for me I was to write about my
life and share it with people and and
that's what I'm doing now so that's
that's a miracle a miracle is when you
get much more than what you were
expecting and so I'm living in a miracle
right now a meditation that I do before
I go onstage I would share with you
before I go on stage I say I go through
my whole life and you can do it in three
minutes and I say help me choose to be a
vessel to be someone greater than myself
and bring joy and forgiveness and
healing and love and then I go on stage
[Music]